[Música]
llegó el momento de hablar de salud en
directo a américa porque ecuador empieza
hoy la vacunación de niños y niñas
mayores de 5 años para ello ya está
conmigo en el estudio más romeros a la
mar bienvenida feliz el lunes feliz
inicio de semana para usted muchas
gracias y si quieres empecemos repasando
cuáles son las decisiones de los
distintos países de américa latina-
alrededor de la vacunación de menores de
año de edad porque son bastante dispares
por ejemplo méxico-brasil no están
vacunando a menores de 18 años a no ser
que tengan comorbilidades algunos
riesgos no la mayoría de los países
están vacunando a partir de los 12 años
entre los cuales contamos con colombia
por ejemplo perú mientras tanto chile
está vacunando los mayores de seis
ecuador como hemos dicho a partir de los
cinco años argentina de venezuela han
bajado el límite a los tres años y
nicaragua y cuba son los países que
están vacunando desde más temprana edad
con los fármacos desarrollados
precisamente por cuba a partir de los 2
años de edad para hablar de todo esto
estamos con el doctor carlos eduardo
pérez médico infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia como
cada lunes muy buenos días doctor
cuéntenos
entre otros y los países que están
vacunando menores de 12 años lo hacen
principalmente con sinovac y también han
anunciado que con facer es porque son
las más seguras para los niños o es
porque han sido las más rápidas en
desarrollar los datos
si es son las dos cosas primero la
vacuna de sinovac tiene esa indicación
de 5 a 17 años que de 3 a 17 años y que
el chile adoptó hace un par de meses y
la vacuna de falset viene con la
preparación espacial para la población
pediátrica son buenas noticias y que en
el mundo se está abriendo la vacunación
a los niños es una cosa y un paso muy
importante del control de la pandemia
vamos a esperar como al expriísta el
ecuador para que los demás países de
américa latina la red con doctor félix
lunes madrugando leal festivo como
nosotros acá en el estudio le pregunto
qué dicen los datos que respaldan el uso
de estas vacunas en niños y niñas
tierra buenos días en uno de los
principales
puntos es que hay varias poblaciones
pediátricas y la formulación es distinta
la dosis es un tercio de la vacuna de
facer convencional eso no se hace con
discusiones o bien en la preparación
especial va a ser para niños entre 5 y
11 años otra formulación entre 3 y 5
años y otra formulación a niños mayores
de 6 meses en el transcurso del año se
está sometiendo a las entidades
regulatorias de eeuu de esas
preparaciones para poder evaluar ya está
establecida la seguridad la aprobación
para poder masificar la vacuna en 2000
pero recordemos que no es diluir la
vacuna que tenemos actualmente son
preparaciones especiales que vienen para
la población pediátrica con técnicas
distintas de preparación parece que hay
como una barrera en los 12 años no tanto
para los estudios como para los
gobiernos las autoridades médicas porque
específicamente en esta edad se hace la
distinción
la población infantil es una población
protegida debe ser con la autorización
de sus padres que sean llevados a
necesitar esto es crimen
recordemos que estos son estudios
clínicos que se hacen de fase 3 son
estudios experimentales ya cuando se
aprueba la una de esas una fase distinta
y para eso se necesita el visto bueno de
los padres el comité y acá hacer una
serie de procesos que es mucho más
complejo que la población adulta
convencional aquí tenemos que contar con
las familias para que un niño se someta
en estudio tiene que tener resultados
realmente es una gran familia de
valientes y gracias a ellos es que
tenemos los resultados prometedores y al
fin de año vamos a observar una real
infancia en la mayoría de partes del
mundo ahora autores le pregunta las
consecuencias que tiene en vacunar a los
menores de edad sobre la sociedad en
general
es un hecho fundamental porque la
vacunación y la inmunidad colectiva no
se logra vacunando personas mayores de
12 años o 18 años es vacunando todo el
planeta incluye los niños desde la
primera infancia desde los primeros
meses de vida entonces cuando hablamos
de coberturas de 70 por ciento de las
personas vacunas es incluyendo
efectivamente la población infantil por
eso estas noticias son de verdad que muy
importantes porque reducen la
probabilidad de que digamos en pandemia
porque esta población infantil va a ser
vacunada y las vacunas han demostrado
ser seguras y muy efectivas ni
parece que el hobbit 19 hemos visto a lo
largo de todo este tiempo de pandemia
afecta un poco menos a los niños a la
infancia entonces es prioritaria la
distribución de la vacuna de las vacunas
en estos rangos de edad cuando todavía
sabemos que hay muchísima desigualdad en
el acceso a estos fármacos
digamos que era asimetría de las vacunas
es patente las terceras dosis una
población pediátrica mientras hay países
del mundo que no tienen ni uno por
ciento de cobertura vacunal pues habla
mucho de esta asimetría sin embargo la
vacunación en los niños es un hecho
fundamental porque frenará ese episodio
de pandemia recordemos que los niños no
fallecen pero si tienen las
complicaciones inmunológicas en algunos
de los niños que les da hoy y por eso es
necesario también proteger los infantes
no sólo por la memoria colectiva sino
para evitar esas complicaciones pero sin
duda el mundo le debe una explicación a
estas estrategias globales de vacunación
porque la pobla y la vacunación sigue
siendo asimétrica desigual y marca una
diferencia entre países desarrollados y
en vías de desarrollo demasiado marcada
en lo que necesitamos como mundo que es
una vacuna pues doctor muchísimas
gracias por toda la información en
cuanto a la vacunación de niños mayores
de 5 años hablamos por el caso de
ecuador que lo comienza a cero y
muchísimas gracias doctor que tengo
usted un feliz resto día gracias vamos
ahora con nuestro segundo invitado el
día